le gouvernement qui a donc décidé de
faire la guerre au passoir thermique
bonjour Louis Quentin bonjour David
président de la FNAME l'objectif on
comprend bien de cette loi climat
résilience cette motivé les
propriétaires pour qu'ils réalisent ces
travaux donc d'isolation pour rendre
plus performant
leur logement d'un point de vue
énergétique est-ce que c'est un peu la
manière forte c'est une bonne façon de
faire pour vous c'est un mauvais signal
envoyé aux propriétaires dans un
contexte où logement des locatif est
déjà sous tension donc il faut plutôt
créer une incitation plutôt que de
l'interdiction et l'indécence au 1er
janvier 2025 place les propriétaires
dans l'urgence à réaliser des travaux
qu'ils ne pourront peut-être pas
forcément réaliser soit ils sont en
copropriété ou non pas forcément une
possibilité d'intervenir sur le logement
de façon directe plutôt que de rénover
certains propriétaires bailleurs
pourraient être contraints de vendre
peut-être avec une décote alors oui
quand on un propriétaire décide je ne
veux pas relouer parce que mon locataire
s'en va je ne veux pas être exposé à des
travaux donc il va décider de mettre
en vente son logement on voit quelque
chose depuis le début
certains propriétaires prennent la
décision quand le locataire s'en va
s'ils sont c'est un logement classique
de vendre vous savez un propriétaire qui
a 80 ans qui a des petits revenus qui
n'a pas forcément les moyens d'engager
des travaux ces enfants vont lui dire
écouter écoute qu'on conseille de vendre
plutôt que de le conserver en location
donc c'est un signal qui n'est pas de
nature à faciliter une offre locative de
qualité après il y a aussi je réfléchis
mais la question du pour le coup du du
locataire que faire du locataire enfin
que faire que fait le propriétaire
d'ailleurs du locataire pendant la durée
des travaux il pourra pas lui donner
congé au motif qui les rénove
son logement donc il faut il faut le
reloger il faut des indemnités il y a la
loi n'a prévu aucune autre disposition
que celle qui sont contenues dans la loi
6 juillet 89 qui régit les rapports
locatifs entre bailleur et propriétaire
c'est entre bailleur et locataire à
savoir que un propriétaire ne peut
donner congé que pour vendre ce logement
le reprendre pour son usage donc
qu'est-ce qui concrètement il est obligé
de donner des congés pour vendre s'il ne
veut pas réaliser les travaux ou alors
il est obligé son logement mais la
difficulté c'est impossible Mission
Impossible de ce côté-là aussi également
d'autant qu'il y a le coup on l'a pas
dit le Quentin mais il y a le coup la
rénovation entre 25000 €, 25000 € c'est
une moyenne pour un appartement 45000 €
pour une maison et pour certains
pavillons la facture peut grimper
jusqu'à 60
000 euros pour beaucoup de Français
c'est évidemment beaucoup trop cher
comment on règle ce problème là même
s'il y a ma prime rénover on va en
parler c'est vrai que le coût de la
rénovation où vous soyez dans le Cantal
ou à Paris il est exactement le même
mais le prix de la valeur vénale du bien
affiché n'est pas du tout la même dans
la proportion des travaux n'est pas du
tout comparable donc il y a des secteurs
qui vont être encore plus en difficulté
face à l'obligations de de travaux quand
on est en immeuble il faut avoir en plus
l'accord d'une majorité de
copropriétaires pour faire les travaux
ce qui rajoute encore une fois c'est
encore beaucoup de temps il faut si je
vous exploser tout le mécanisme de la
rénovation énergétique avec un plan
pluriel de travaux avec une consultation
avec des une des préconisations qui sont
mises en splantes urinelle de travaux
que vont solliciter les propriétaires le
choix le choix des travaux réalisés la
consultation des entreprises les recours
éventuelles contre la décision la
réalisation des travaux donc les
rénovations se font souvent dans des
dans le parc privé au sein des logements
d'un seul logement ou d'une maison en
propriété il y a aucun problème aucune
difficulté il y a un seul maître
d'ouvrage il procède à la commande il
réalise
bien évidemment à ce qu'on ce qu'on
demande et dans tous les cas à la fois
je dirais de suspendre d'abord c'est
indécence énergétique à la réalisation
des travaux dans les ensembles locaux
propriétés permettent aux propriétaires
de continuer à louer et éviter qu'il y
ait justement cette attrition du parc
locatif qui est dommageable pour le
logement en France bon pied un obstacle
aussi un autre obstacle j'ai envie de
dire pour les ménages c'est que c'est
long la rénovation encore une fois d'un
logement c'est long c'est fastidieux il
faut même parfois quitter son propre
logement pendant
quelques mois et donc évidemment c'est
un facteur bloquant pour pour déménages
oui je crois que les gros travaux seront
bien évidemment sur les sur les
carcasses sur les structures sur les
gros travaux sur les ravalement les
isolations par l'extérieur les travaux
dans dans les combles les parties
communes les appareils de chauffage
chauffage collectif Les menustries c'est
quelque chose qui peut être géré les
ménages sont habitués et ça se peut se
gérer mais ce qui est plus important ce
qui peut inquiétant c'est de trouver les
entreprises pour le faire parce que
quand on parle de rénovation énergétique
il faut faire obligatoirement appel pour
être bénéficiaire de ces aides appelle
les entreprises qualifiées RG
responsable garante de l'environnement
et on entreprises de on a aujourd'hui
sur un million 300000 entreprises dans
la construction le bâtiment et
l'artisanat on a précisément 65000
entreprises qui sont qualifiées RGE et
on a perdu 3000 entreprises qualifiées
RGE afin 2022 Bruno Le Maire lui-même
disait qu'il fallait multiplier par 4 le
nombre de ces entreprises pour procéder
ces travaux de rénovation énergétique
donc aujourd'hui nous sommes dans
l'incapacité l'impossibilité de répondre
à cette à cette commande et d'avoir des
entreprises qualifiées allez merci
beaucoup merci Loïc Quentin donc le
président de la famille merci à vous
merci David alors se lancer dans la
rénovation
[Musique]